two other places that i know that you
spent a lot of time thinking about
writing about or learning is cuba and
nigeria um both two different situations
maybe talk a little bit about cuba first
and then we talk about nigeria just in
terms of uh during this kind of uh
revolution or protest that's going on in
cuba uh obviously there tends to be uh
kind of a bitcoin movement movement that
goes along with it so what's going on in
cuba
yeah well i mean obviously to us but but
most people don't don't see
what's happening with bitcoin in cuba
i wrote a kind of a deep dive into what
i would call bitcoins
or rather cuba's peaceful bitcoin
revolution for bitcoin magazine uh two
weeks ago
and i think it's important to note that
like cubans are going through the
hardest time
economically that they've gone through
since the early 90s
uh
ever since
fidel and che created modern cuba
in 59
they became incredibly dependent on the
soviet union uh for everything i mean
they basically exported all their sugar
there soviets bought the sugar at a
higher than market price uh really the
soviets kind of kept cuba alive and so
when the soviet union fell cuba went
into something called the special period
in the early 90s where they you know
they just were sort of strangled
economically they didn't have any way of
generating money
and the peso collapsed their currency
went from being like five to a dollar to
like 150 to a dollar
um and people started like using dollars
actually there was like a dollarization
that happened in cuba similar to what's
happening in venezuela now
um and to prevent that from like really
taking over because obviously that's
like the enemy's currency if you're
fidel right you don't want people using
american money
he created a fake dollar called the cuc
or the convertible peso in 94.
um and this was this has been you know
was used heavily until earlier this year
and what ended up happening was like the
greatest rug pull of all time because
between 94 and 2004
cubans used dollars they used these like
cucs they used pesos um and it was kind
of all floating and and cubans owned
dollars like cubans had dollars at home
they had dollars in bank accounts in
cuba like u.s dollars right in 2004 the
government came out and said no no no
more dollars so they took all the
dollars and they replaced them with
these fake dollars so you what you saw
is like the the cuban people holding the
hard currency the actual usd
all of a sudden the government was
holding it and they were holding these
a bag of this you know fake dollars
which were just phased out right earlier
this year so this is like a giant rug
pull where the government is like
stealing
time and energy from the people it's
really tragic so now they have a new
scheme called the mlc which is even
crazier because
essentially in cuba there's like
different kinds of stores right you have
your like rations like bottom barrel
kind of essentials that the government
kind of hands out which are not enough
to live off of at all so you have to
actually go buy stuff with money in
stores and the stores today that that
have good stuff only accept something
called an mlc
now an mlc is like almost like a gift
card account you have to top it up but
get this you can't top it up with pesos
so most people in cuba they work for the
state they make pesos or their pension
is paid out in pesos so they have to go
to the black market and exchange their
pesos for mlc
at a at the black market rate and the
government says the rate's one to 24 uh
in terms of uh a dollar to peso on the
street it's one to seventy right so the
government's just stealing from the
people and they're forcing them to
actually get their family abroad to top
up their mlc account with pounds or
euros or you know pay you know brazilian
currency etc um
and that's the only way you can buy
stuff at stores to survive you need like
an air conditioner if you need good food
meat whatever you gotta you gotta use
mlc so this is another rug pull where
the government is basically paying its
workers in in collapsing pesos but
collecting hard currency from abroad and
and this there's just so much injustice
in this and yes the united states
embargo is a big part of the problem 100
really at the end of the day it's like
the dictatorship and this economic kind
of exploitation system they have i mean
think about it cuba's biggest export
is is is essentially indentured
servitude of medical personnel that
literally their biggest export it's like
11 billion a year is sending nurses and
doctors to countries abroad
and the state takes 75 percent of their
wages
the second biggest export is you know
either tourism or sugar etc but like
this is a state built on exploitation
and people have had enough of it and
what's interesting is in my interviews
with cubans all over the island
it's not just dissidents or you know
pro-democracy opposition folks who are
using bitcoin it's also the communists
this is we call this the money of
enemies i mean anybody can use it so you
have people who are hardcore communists
who believe in the revolution and all
this stuff they're using bitcoin and
then of course you have all the you know
people who are more like uh screw the
government they're using bitcoin too
um but it it's it's just remarkable to
see
and it is a microcosm of what you're
seeing all across the world today and
people are fed up with the money system
it doesn't work it's it's essentially a
scam in many places um and they're
opting into something that's not a scam
they're opting into something that's
like hard money that's going to be there
for them in the future hey guys thanks
so much for watching that clip of the
best business show make sure you like
and subscribe to the channel turn on
notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it